ready for his padres debut on the mound
blake snell aka snelzilla
elevates and strikes out la castro good
start in the padres uniform for blake
snell
[Music]
on the ground to short tattis has got it
his throw is good two outs on the first
down
now ready to go here's the pitch and a
swing of the miss that's the slider and
that's the second strikeout of the
inning blake snell starts it off with a
bang pitcher for the diamondbacks
merrill kelly 32 year old reinhander
coming off thoracic outlet surgery last
fall
got that one down and in
as drupal cabrera in front of rojas and
there's one away three defenders on the
third base side walker the only defender
between first and second
fastball at the days ring them up and
sit him down strikeout number one
for merrill kelly
that breaking ball left it in a bad spot
but gets away with it
and merrill kelly counters blake's now
with one two three first outside of the
camo this is the only home uniform the
padres have now here's the two and two
escobar swings and misses strike three
pitch in the dirt a filthy curveball and
the third strikeout already for blake
snell one away in the top of the second
inning with the switch hitting his
drubal cabrera coming up just talked
about it the 1-2 pitch
was up out of the zone changed the eye
level
and then he comes with the nasty curve
ball at about 80 miles per hour starts
in the middle of the zone falls off the
table
osmore in third
fires at second
coneworth at first
luis compusado
[Applause]
got it in
here comes matheson pretty shallow left
and everybody's gonna have to hold up
there you go nobody advances and that's
out number one big number one out right
there
in the air to right field
castro's gonna have room as he moves
back to make the catch on the track
hosmer will tag and score and the padres
are on the board
that's what he does to look at strike
three
down here oh and two to blake snell
blake ready delivers swinging a miss he
strikes out again and that is number
four for blake snell a fastball
swinging a miss for walker
he strikes out
takes with him the fifth strikeout for
stella that's the second time walker has
been down by way of the k tonight
runners will be off on the 3-2
struck him out
second time escobar struck out six k's
for blake snell threw through two and a
half padres have a one-nothing lead and
the padres with runners on first and
second one away and they'll leave it up
to the hot hitting eric hospital runners
on the move throw to third
got him they get tattace at third
machado moves into second double steal
attempt and carson kelly is ready
hosmer to right the castro goes back
looks up and it's gone
two-run home run for eric hosmer and the
padres take a three-nothing lead at san
diego
hosmer homered on opening day he's
homered in game two padres run into an
out and hasbro barrels this one up belt
buckle high
lean on me
listen to this
wow
got him
needed that and picks up his seventh
strikeout and his first start in the
padres uniform two down
bringing the heater there's the four
seamer up and away very late is mathison
oh yeah
[Applause]
kelly goes around and strikes out that's
the eighth strikeout for blake stalls
[Applause]
one hopper to the backhand of tatis the
throw that he bounces there on purpose
and gets him
nice play by fernando tatis jr i love
the on purpose bounce as you were
mentioning don
get it there
oh that's close
boy what a nice play on both ends
[Applause]
just gets it
beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
fly ball to right field down the line
myers headed towards foul ground full
board to get there in time
spins and fires back in the infield
myers with a good running catch
and blake snell
will be leaving after four and two
thirds innings tonight
this crowd will let him know what they
think of his work tonight is padres
debut
high pop up in the shadow left t south
mateo in look out and it's tatissu makes
the catch but they collide sort of
and mateo
it's a little bit of the worst of it
although tatis
hobbling a bit and that is the absolute
last thing you want to say
it's a miscommunication on a fly ball to
left
they will both walk off appear to be
okay base is filled with friars
padres a three-nothing lead in the
bottom of the fifth chance to bust it
open here bases loaded two out
lift it up
myers popped it up
walker and foul ground
and johan lopez walks a high wire but
leaves him loaded
punches it the other way it backs up
mateo still backing up and it's gone
cattell marte
his second home run in as many games and
suddenly it's a one-run ball game
[Applause]
on the ground through a vacated left
side
fan being waved around he will score and
the padres take a 4-2 lead eric hosmer's
on fire to begin the 2021 season
back looking for his second save in a
padres uniform in as many days
2-2
in the air to center field it's fam on
the move he'll get there one down in the
ninth
kattel martay hit a two-run home run
back in the seventh
and give the diamondbacks the two runs
they have here he is with a tying run at
first base right now
on the ground right side kronerworth
will go to first and the padres win
mark malanson picks up his second save
one in each of the first two padres
games in 2021